greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happened now is brought to you by
manscaped precision tools for the family
jewels listen this thanksgiving if you
wanted to say gobble gobble you got to
trim it up down there a little bit you
can't go down there looking like any
months as IDI do don't let bad hair Jean
get it hygiene hygiene hygiene get
between you and the stuffing and I'm
saying carve up that love stick with
manscape they created the only tool you
need to shave the pole of debt and shave
your balls it's called a lawn mower 2.0
for a reason and right now the church
family gets 20% off your first thought
listen to what I'm saying to you 20% off
your first order to keep you [ __ ]
loved stick tip top Magoo you understand
me shave their head you know have you
looked down there lately
it's a nightmare I don't care how old
you are it's a nightmare we don't look
this man we go out there like what the
world blows is something the world don't
know you dick understand me go to
manscape calm right now shave that love
stick shave around in that area and see
how much girls will love you even more
when they get that nut right in your
mouth and then look it does not taste
like a chocolate-covered strawberry
understand but the church family gets
20% off your first daughter when you use
Church and manscaped calm and if you
order the perfect perfect package which
I'll tell you at the end of the show
don't threw in a free travel bag just
when you use the code Church all right
that's manscape calm use promo code
Church CH you are CH to get 20% off your
first daughter clean that mother [ __ ]
love stick area number two the church is
brought to you by Howell Turkey like joy
what's hallo Toshi
hello Toshi is a portable bidet tha it
takes you 10 minutes to install yourself
on your toilet and it basically changes
your whole life you don't understand
what it's like to sit there no more
toilet paper no more cutting down trees
no more little Arab looking little
Mexicans running down the jungle
cutting trees and stuff no more that we
eliminate that whole process what do you
want to do wipe they wipe with toilet
you wipe your butt with toilet paper but
you still leave the microbe in the jar
Johnny which cause a variety of
different things like hemorrhoids yeast
infections UTI not to mention the
classic is she [ __ ] and skid marks
which at fifty six I still get from time
to time I should be shutting up listen
but days are common all over the world
but they saves you money on toilet paper
cushy the bidet
sprays you a little muffler with fresh
water it's not toilet water so she
connects to the water supply behind your
toilet spray you understand me is the
same same water you brush your teeth
with do me a favor
they started $79 it's the most amazing
unconditional gift you give anybody in
your life and listen everybody needs one
take a look at your mother next time you
go whatever Thanks
look at her ass looks like with all
those dimples and [ __ ] if they need some
anybody needs a bidet it's your mom
start with your mom get a lift up give
me the gift of love watch your ass mom
go - hello - she calm right now and
pressing Church CH you are CH and get
10% off your litter she starts at $79
again hello - she calm / Church and get
10% off your first order meal kick this
mutely you know I'm saying uncle Joey
here just giving you a little pep talk
before the holidays until it's over
Thanksgivings here he was sitting there
scratching head
Halloween's at the time I'm gonna be the
wolf man the gay wolf man this year and
[ __ ] went and passed it snakes giving
tomorrow you'll be sitting there with a
bunch of people looking at him some of
years go to those hobo Thanksgivings
where you don't know nobody and you get
that nobody's got teeth there's one god
it's afternoon and he's offering you
stuff and you need that in your life you
know saying I'm gonna have a little
shame thing tamales coming over Kay
quick he's coming over the essentials
family but it's all about on
Thanksgiving Sunday night I was at the
Comedy Store my Han told conversation I
was really funny it was funny at first
but then I went home and I thought about
what had transpired him what it said and
I felt sad I felt so sad I called Dean
Del Ray one in the morning really and we
talked for about an hour
because yeah was a conversation about
the movie the Joker
and it was any if a couple guys to back
and Elias was saying how he didn't enjoy
the film
because it had some type of it let the
public know that it's okay to shoot
people or something and then Alonzo
Bodden was sitting there you know guy
was like he fixed the airplanes for a
living he worked for Boeing and he
seemed in an interesting point when it
was on stage because I enjoyed the movie
but it'll also let me know how that's
every comic you know that that could
happen to every comic you know because
of the highs and the lows and I went on
stage and you know I got it off when I
talked to Whitney and I talked to this
guy and he say hello the Mart and then
you really forget and like as I was
driving my Laurel Canyon a fact came
into my mind that not a lot of people
know but I'll tell you from 1995 to 2000
I was pretty much homeless guys it was
every day was a different story
it's where I ended up well I left bold
the June of 85 95 I'm sorry I left with
a car filled with stuff the essentials
you know and I packed up some stuff in
storage and I thought I was gonna come
back but in my heart I knew I wasn't
coming back you know with a live Nova
you were going to Seattle I was going to
Seattle but I was gonna go do this
comedy thing I was gonna go see what it
was really about I had had a touch of
the road already I knew what the road
was about I had I had featured at a club
already but now really it was like a sea
Club I was one of the comedy underground
you know a well known Club and I didn't
know anybody or whatever and I went up
there and I would do it with a with the
stripper you know my dear friend and you
know my name wasn't on the lease she
throw me out every two months or
somebody's house and then we lived in a
trailer it was her trailer and then I
came down here and we broke up like in
97
and pretty much from 97 and a half to
2000 I was pretty much homeless like
that would make somebody go you don't
want much do I really love comedy I
don't think I was a little time to get a
job and really assess my life and I just
had no other choices I had no other
options I tried everything already did
any part of you thinking about going
back to selling drugs or oh yeah the
plan was the failure and to go back to
New Jersey just swing and swing until I
died
whatever that means none of that means
how far like what what did failure mean
to you if being homeless wasn't there
yet fail it was spinning my wheels which
I felt the downside I wasn't and
actually my instincts were correct
spinning my wheels at least I was
getting spots at the store I would go to
the store at 9:05 and take a shower some
days and I would go about my day and
then I go back in there about 7:15
quarter to 7:00 6:30
before the bartender's got there and I
go on the main road take another shower
and I'd be ready for the night you know
and just thinking about all those things
got me so depressed I called Dina
because as of two or three years ago you
know when Dean started on the podcast
Dean would go to New York it would be
basically homeless he would start every
day at 12:00 and go to a coffee shop and
write jokes and then hit all these open
mikes and hit some paid gigs to put some
change in his pocket and then he would
walk around and go on that hotel app
well hotel tonight in hotel tonight and
he'd wait till 10 o'clock to get a room
and I got to be honest with you and you
guys know me there was a lot of nights i
sat there going trying to send him 300
hours like why is he doing this and
right before I was about to pick up the
phone to send them the money they dawned
on me that this is what you have to do
this is to sacrifice this is the
this proves to you that what you're
doing this makes you committed into what
you're doing you know I had tons of
highs on loves when I got here a couple
of them were suicidal as [ __ ] that most
people would ice themselves or most
people would quit you know one came up
in particular with Dean where you know
when you start auditioning you get lucky
at first you know knowledge is is not
power sometimes going in there not
knowing what's going on his way better
sometimes sometimes you're at the
jackpot not not even knowing and then
when you get smart you don't book dick
right for years once you know what
you're doing you won't book nothing then
you go when's it maybe I should go back
to what I was doing yeah so you don't
really know but for a year I had a
manager that was a real manager his job
was to get you out everything get you on
a TV show and Lee when that it would all
his heart on a daily basis this guy
would fight he was a fighter Jewish guy
one of those desert Jews short and you
know yarmulke wearing but man when he
went to work in the morning he went to
work there was nights he would call me
at 12:30 at night with an audition
you know who's texting me like who's
paging me and it would be him and I'd go
like what what's going on he's like I
just emailed you a script go home read
it you gotta be in there by 10 o'clock
tomorrow like that type of stuff so for
a year I took a beatin Lee just going
auditions walking out and saying I got
this role and then I wouldn't even hear
back from them right you know after they
were like be like thank you for coming
in it was so nice meeting you
we're gonna come to the store and watch
you one that I would just go into the
bag and Dick's pretty much and this one
on from 98 to about 2006 of going into
things big things like I was going to
sow I remember going into famine man men
in black to him like I remember going in
for the first woman gone I rolled a
cress that's her cast that's the casting
agent roll the crest was huge then like
have you gotten to see Ron or crass
people calling
who do you have as representation there
was three or four people that you could
not get in with in those days like the
lady who cast buying a man - she cares
pretty woman as a bunch of other things
damn she wouldn't see I don't even know
how I got in there the guy that casts he
cast the Walter Hill movies and all of
blade and all those movies Ruben I
forget what his name is black dude
gentlemen of dude that's what you used
to have to pre really well that's what
you used to have to go and read for an
assistant and if the assistant thought
you were good enough then you go home
and get a call and go back the next day
and recently casting director Jesus
friend than if he liked you he called
you back again this is one budgets when
they were allowing budgets to cast
people like real now if you know
anything about casting they cast right
from the sheet like they just go down
the sheet and call they just put her
office out I had an audition when I when
I first busted up Mike Mike I like my
leg and I was like I don't know if I
should go or not and I called him like
Alissa I'm not gonna make it because of
my leg can I put it on tape the audition
was at 4:00 at 4:45 they call me back
I'm like oh no they already made an
offer to somebody so they were gonna
make me drive all over the [ __ ]
breathe even though they had made an
offer to somebody right that's the type
of world we live in today back then they
would they wouldn't lie to you Mike and
that Walter Hill had walked the Hill
audition it was a movie with Ving Rhames
and Ruben and uh it was Ving Rhames and
the guy who went to jail for taxes for
blade oh yeah okay it was him and I'll
never forget that I swear to God I must
have gone in seven times to read for
that for the Travolta movie seven or
eight times in lines and they give you
different lines same lines sometimes I
expand the script sometimes they give
you all your scenes from the movie so
they make sure you can read all the
scenes from the movie and you're gonna
handle it it was just buck wild you know
I remember reading for the Sopranos and
the papers shaking but my point is
you do it's tough not to snap it's tough
not this snap is economic and like that
night no I didn't sleep much that night
and because that that's how much it
affected me like what I went through to
get here like the mud that I went
through to get here you know I used to
be really hot this time of the year
right now is my time of the year like
the commercials aw I would burn them
right now because this is so Super Bowl
time and it's also we have to shoot this
pilot time and I'll never forget like
every year during the holidays I had
made I couldn't enjoy the holiday they
ruined my holidays better yet I let them
on my holidays because of my weak mind
you know when I walk into an audition
now and I do an audition I walk out and
I get my car it's done it's done Lee
it's done and people look at me go how
do you do that it's 20 years like
there's no use of taking this home with
me but there was a time when you're
slipping on somebody's couch that you
need this this is not a joke you need
this you need this worse than ever
and there was one particular time that I
came all the way home because when I
read the script I go I can't say
anybody's doing this he was a shelf or a
fox or NBC it was NBC you know the crazy
room made the straight two white guys I
forget who the lead was hey but I came
all the way off the road had to sleep on
a couch like I think Ralphie was out of
town he took the keys so nobody could go
in this I killed me sleep on a couch I
didn't have a car that my apartment got
towed then that's when my apartment
sleep on this guy's couch and from
December like 6:00 the torture started
like December 6 started come on we want
to read Joey Diaz went down that red
came back two days later want to read
you again went down there read again
don't want to read you again they read
with four guys so I'll read with the
four guys they were looking at and see
how we look together in the room went
back down and read with each guy
individually and the weekend hit went
back down there all week later and read
new lines and revisions and then went
down and they made me go to stage and we
had to do the scene on stage whoa okay
with the paper and you have like a
little player for the scene they taped
that that went on till December 19th so
two weeks allow my god so for two weeks
my whole life was embroidered in that
yeah there were other auditions and
other stuff and then boom the holiday
said I didn't hear nothing I mean I was
past staring at your phone I was staring
I would sleep with the pager
I needed this job this wasn't the job I
needed this
whatever the pilot paid 15 grand and
then when I really episodes were after
that I could care less what they were
this was in my world the owned and the
my dilemma do you know I'm saying right
yeah I saw it as a means to an end so
when you see things as a means to an end
they hurt more they heard a lot lot more
and I never forget that I had to wait it
out from the like 19th like the fourth
to fifth of January and that first
morning I called them and I go man I'm
gonna tell me what's going on he goes
this has been the worst holiday season
because they called me on the 24th and I
go what they tell any ghosts they went
with a black guy so two weeks of driving
to Orange County I got nothing against
black guys because I guess black people
but it takes your heart it just rings it
it just rings it you know and you're
getting 10 of those and 10 of the shot
like I still imma Steve Rannazzisi comes
up to me like with tears in his eyes on
them Bobby Lee all those guys we all
went through a patch
you really start to test your salary you
tried to not test it but you start to
question it like what am i doing
what am i doing and then you go home
pick up the pieces and there you are on
the next day and you know you hurt when
you hear you didn't get the role you
hurt and then you know what the crazy
thing is that all that pain that you
went through and all that anguish the
show gets made it gets picked up you
curse it you're cursing it the whole
time [ __ ] you I hope you fail and sure
enough there's six episodes and the show
gets cancelled right and you feel so
much better now you're like you know so
I've learned over these at the roles I
didn't get like they didn't matter
like once you know I didn't really
matter once they were done but it's
easier looking at it
20 years later cuz I get I've thought
about this like about the Joker I mean
obviously we're in comedy and stand-up
and acting but something that I've come
to realize as I've gotten older how you
should look at like remember when Martin
Lawrence run down the street crazy I was
like oh wow he's created the older I get
I'm like I can see how just you can
happy having a bad couple weeks and one
guy like cuts you off on the freeway
he's like I could see that happening a
lot more clearly now
like people don't number applying their
jobs and that's the same thing you don't
hear back from them they they they have
to have you come interview and you you
drive all the way down then the
interview takes three minutes so the
person doesn't show up for an hour words
that's like I I used to think crazy
people were just crazy and some of them
are but I think there's just some things
that you could just snap I think it's
easier than it's not I could be I could
lie to you people tell you that I know
there were about three times I was gonna
snap and I know about times that I did
snap because of a situation
and I went off on somebody else about
something else because of that initial
situation which a lot of us do
what's so angry that we got towed our
brother calls us this is are you coming
home for Thanksgiving like oh how the
hell you know I know you got a beef
because you without a line they were out
of line I could see myself you know I
haven't watched the Joker yet I am gonna
watch it I just didn't want to go to the
movies and stuff and I didn't have time
that weekend the whole thing I'm gonna
watch when it comes out of play in the
Sun but I could watch a movie and that
was it was just it's really hard to
swallow what mine feels I walked through
the get here like that night it made me
realize and again I go back to a
conversation that I've discussed on the
podcast before you know my only
conversation ever would / was at the
Riviera and he was like are you happy in
your life now and I'm like I'm happy you
know he goes are you broken I'm real
broke you know this is gonna be the best
time of your life because when you get
the big checks you're gonna look at this
time and you're gonna understand why you
got those checks when you start you know
selling out like a club or something
like that and you don't have to doubt
yourself a lot of people start dialing
themselves they really do they try to
cap what's that word not camouflage they
try to you know like bombard their own
success they stand in self-sabotage
they self-sabotage themselves because
they don't think they should be they
deserve what they're doing but that
night really made me go oh okay like
that like I really lost sleep over it I
couldn't wait to do the podcast to talk
about this and like I said I had to call
Dean and Dean was like I don't think
people know that Dean did three years he
did I think he said nine hundred gigs on
a motorcycle he goes I drove to San
Diego and he goes I drove as far as
Portland Oregon on a motorcycle do
spot and he goes I could tell you right
now I wouldn't do it again I think is I
don't know what I was thinking at the
time but that's the process you know
that's uh I don't my dog there were
plenty of times when I went home and
said this is it I'm not doing this well
I mean you and Dean have somebody till
this small extent me because I started
29 which is old but not super old but
Dean started at 50 I can't imagine being
50 and an open-mic with 21 year olds you
were he was 46 of 46 and you were
30-something I think I was 28 1990 okay
so it was 1993 would make me 30 so 1991
I was 28 first time I got on stage I was
almost 20 it's uh
I can't imagine starts with 46 I had
life experiences I didn't have the heart
to talk about I'm on stage I have wanted
them like a plague I didn't start
talking about prison till the podcast
really or maybe Joe Rogan's podcast yeah
[ __ ] I wouldn't talk about it what's the
price eggs how wrong was I it's got
everything to do with the price axe but
it's really real well the ones who said
that night how there's so many highs and
there's so many lows I mean you could be
opening up for Tom Segura on Saturday
night and come home on a plane on a
private plane or and then the following
Friday you're getting in a car and
driving to San Jose for feature money
and driving back Sunday night which is
six hours and you're in the car going
last week I was in a private plane Tom
Segura and this week I'm driving to San
Jose in my car which Bell he's not gonna
make it like I've gotten in cars that I
knew wasn't gonna make it
did you ever do that like if it makes it
it's gonna be a miracle or not they've
got the feature actors behind me or the
emcee and he'll pick me up on just
abandon ship on the road
Jesus I had a shitty car but I didn't
take long trips like that oh yeah you
know this is part of the you changed the
oil you changed that all filter
breakfast you put that thing in the
radiator sore wall blow and the
old-school cars you would put these
little plugs a little plugs oh yeah
and like that the out of your uh thing
one week and it's just that the price
you pay I sit I sit here now and I go
you know I did things that were
completely out of my realm that I would
not even consider doing by hard time
going to summer eleven eleven o'clock to
get a kombucha juice like seriously like
if I'm at home like 11 o'clock
that's scary out there maybe I'll go to
one by the open mic over there like that
one enough I'll go in there I might not
cuz I don't want to see those people if
you go to the one over here you got
homeless Johnny no legs the one that we
put the light beams and the right balls
that night she was giving us the finger
you know I'm ceated that yeah I was
scared to death you know there was a
time when I lived to do comedy because
they would feed me like I was in great
shape
all you would say involved yeah because
I had I was really what was that die
you're right
Oh which one the keto no the other one
the low-carb no the other one occasional
starvation Oh fascinating
yeah I was intermittent faster than 95 I
was intermittent fasting from 95 though
I'm a careless drip you know she started
feeding me you know turkey burgers this
stuff like that my life was all a mile
intamin thing fasting I would look at
the people I would eat a sandwich wrap
up the wrap from looking a wrapping
though I don't want to see one of these
again but we'll figure it out yeah you
know jumping over a counter for
a singer it's a Denver International
Airport Norlin thought bathroom and
smoke include you don't have any money
for cigarettes
I'm they had a thousand of these stories
you know taking that bus I lived on the
gram bus on the East Coast lived up and
down Buffalo Syracuse
you know Rochester Toronto back to South
Carolina Myrtle Beach back to New York
you know Philadelphia DC it was just
crazy standing on a bus stop for three
hours and 3:30 in the morning 270 your
bus comes with three dollars in your
pocket see there's different levels to
me like that that to me sounds like kind
of exciting I mean obviously four years
at a time I can see where I would not be
cool to me now that sounds kind of
exciting but the whole well yeah I I
guess it just doesn't make sense in my
head I might not have money to eat
it's pretty [ __ ] but you're gonna
take that money that night after you do
what you really really really want to do
okay okay so you know you got something
yeah I got three dollars but I'm on my
way to a weekend gig got it I'm gonna
pick up $300 it's not I'm still not
gonna be Oh Jed's a millionaire don't
get me wrong
yeah sound by the time I get paid I'm
gonna take 130 and drawers for a bag of
weed a little bit of taste I was gonna
say cuz usually get paid at the end so
you'd go up to be like listen I don't
know you just tell them the truth
you know what on the way up gala
everybody my standard line was I lost my
ATM card okay everywhere I went it was
my ATM card everywhere I went
soon as I got to the club if they said
to go to the hotel I go to the hotel
that's where the war would start do you
have a credit card no I don't that lost
on the plane so how are we gonna check
it I don't know it's called the club and
I would have to call the club the club
owner would have to come and we'll give
him the credit card number over the
phone and then he would call me and I'd
tell my store I have a credit card I
haven't eaten saying the morning eat
okay
but get dinner at the hotel and pull on
my tab it'd be the worst dinner in the
world but but what I care it would be an
end and I'm lined here it wouldn't be
those type of hotels they would be like
the Motel 6's right with potato chips in
the hallway and then down the corner it
would be like a really bad hamburger
spot you know like stuff like that
and I would have to he would come and
bring me cash and drop me off and I
would have to walk back like a half a
mile to my room and then wait and it was
just a abuse cycle it was just a cycle
of abuse but I was working and that's
all that matter that I was working every
weekend I was picking up Tuesdays
picking up Thursdays is that I mean it's
that part of it because like I was
saying when I went with Simone I made in
hit and the guy gave me a bonus but
because I drove but I was supposed to
make 375 I think they gave me 475
something like that for like four days
of work but it really is so much fun
like just like spend it when you're on
luckier you're there for the weekend you
do know you hang out with your buddies
you're working a couple hours at night
making people laugh like is that why you
go through so much [ __ ] because not like
you're on a job like I'm at the cubicle
it like suck and one day it comes to you
that society doesn't work for you
society doesn't fit for you
bobbling is sits at a desk all day bob
willingness is sweetheart I know he
makes good money in the count it yeah
but that's Bob if you'd like to get out
of that job you know and have fun and
goof around but everybody has their
priority sir but it has a family you
know your father pushes you into a
direction you know your father's like I
want you to be a lawyer like me
and then you realize you're miserable
one day when you when you first discover
comedy all right you discovered okay you
watch it but then you get involved with
it but then you take it that extra level
like I was involved with it for two
years and it was fun like you know my
eyes were wide open I didn't say much
and by the 3m mark I started
understanding what was going on around
me I was getting used to the rejection
you know the lives people
when a book you call that number call
the number you know you start realizing
the comedies a lot like life there's no
big differences there's this people who
are pieces of garbage and there's people
who are great people who open their
hearts and their hands to you and you
know give you whatever the hell you need
while you're there it's really weird you
know and I've said it before that
commitment and confidence in the
universe as long as you do what you're
supposed to be doing you'll see it I see
it I still see it I still see it little
bits and pieces as long as you know
you're doing the job you know last night
I was home
it was Monday night so whatever it was
he had Monday night and my wife wasn't
feeling well she wanted better than 8
o'clock I had an option I could sit down
and watch TV I know you called about
11:00 but I was knee-deep in Vietnam
stuff I was getting plane tickets in the
mails I was you know it's it's it's just
so weird that I the work ethic I'm very
proud of my work ethic I'm um it's a
shame my mother died and it's a shame
that it's been 40 years I miss her and
her anniversary was the eighth but I was
soft I was very very soft and the events
that happened made me step up like made
me step up it made me do things that I
never thought I would do and I never
thought I'd want to do back to your
question you know the third and fourth
year of comedy it really is a party it
really is fun once you've established
that a this is what you're gonna do be
you got yourself a little telemarketing
job in the daytime just covering your
bills G just covering your bills you
know why cuz that's all you want to do
that's you got five hours a day for
something else those are the 19 hours
you dedicate the comedy you
eat sleep and dream calmly before you go
to bed you're circling clubs you want to
play you're writing your goals you know
when you want like like I still remember
that the the confusion I lived in when I
was in Boulder 95 from January and 95 to
June of 95 when I knew I was fighting an
uphill battle I knew it was fighting an
uphill battle but then number two I
realized that I was gonna lose the
battle at one point you do realize you
lose the battle and I lost a battle I
made a decision I did to try to do the
best I can and listen you know what by
trying to do the best I can I made out
on top on that deal I lost a daughter
but I made out on top on that deal okay
let's once the fourth and third year
comedy comes you can reject it but it's
falling off your shows because you've
been getting rejected now for two or
three years now 19 hours feel so the
thing is you're going out you're picking
up 25 bucks then you get into to drink
up and drink tickets and you're gonna
get the bartender at 10:00 and drink for
free the rest of the night and you got
your three buddies and your two little
comedy girlfriends and they're married
but they're out you know this is an
eight year you'll see him we got
separated he didn't like me hanging out
at night but guess what people will get
divorced for coming
yeah they will get divorced for coming
once you get that bug you'll lose people
along the way constantly because they
can't handle what you do or how you do
it your lifestyle your lifestyle becomes
different
you ever see major league yeah okay I'm
gonna forget this when the opening one
of the opening scenes have made you
leaves and they're calling around
looking for players right and they
called Tom Berenger he drops down he
picks up the phone he's like all on this
two naked chicks next on I saw that
movie before I started doing triple runs
and in my head I equated that to a
triple run I'm like that's what I'm
gonna be doing that's not what I was
doing there was not one night that I
picked up two girl
come back to a room but I equated that
because I had done my research I had
spoken to all the comics and the comics
I had spoken to you know Grogan made a
point one day to me it's like you know
how many doctors and lawyers are there
how many comedians you know you have to
think about how crazy you have to be to
get into comedy okay how crazy you have
to be I would love for them to publish
like charts but I think they can't do it
I think it's like the census like yeah
when they go looking for homeless people
and they take theirs see how many people
live in the bushes and get the exact
population you'll never get the exact
population of comics because comedies
law like digits you get people do it for
three months you get people do it for
nine months thinking people do it for a
year if you rent it for a year you're
gonna stay in it for five or six years
five or six years when you go I met a
girl I never really liked the road
anyway I met a thousand comics who
looked at me and said I loved comedy
until I had to take a plane to drive see
that's not the most fun part is the most
fun part so that's you know sound like
that that's the traveler I'm working til
that's what you're working towards so
there's a lot of people have come to me
and said this is not I'm gonna do it but
I'm not gonna go on the road I'm going
to do it locally get a day job get
married that with kids and have a family
that's the beauty about doing comedy you
could pick to choose the way of comedy
you want to do yeah it could be a hard
beer could be and there's some people
who this is not you know one again I've
said it again this was not my original
plan and my original plan was not ever
even to come down because I thought I
wouldn't be good enough you know me
having felonies and all the other things
it just wouldn't be good enough but
anyway I just wanted to reiterate to you
people that finally after years I've
convinced myself thanks to you people
and thanks to the feedback and the
emails and whatnot I really have
but I really did go through a minefield
to become a comic it really really
really was a minefield you know and like
I told Dean Theon I go Dean honestly
there was nice when I talked to you I
liked you headed to the east side comedy
club then you headed to two spots at the
cellar and hopefully by that time you'll
find out if you got a hotel room and I
would go out and go no this is part of
the plan this is part of the fun this is
oh you know what happens if you do go to
calm yourself and you meet a girl and
she's like come back to my place you
know you could stay there for a week you
know that's the adventure that you're
looking to get but if you don't go out
there and look for it it's never gonna
come to you it's not the Bluebird of
happiness does not knock on your door
well it's so weird now
I had a couple weird things happen the
last two days Monday was my 10-year
anniversary with my wife and today was
my last doctor's appointment with this
doctor after 21 years
what's one doctor Waxler my empathy
retiring my family doctor of 21 years
the guy that reintroduced me to the
needle I can assign I would not take a
needle him he convinced me to draw blood
he convinced me to do physicals he put
the finger up my ass I'm surprised
you're not making him not retire just
for you like listen you can retire but
he was a very very very good doctor to
me and I want to applaud him he told me
to stay friends with him on Facebook I
gave him a hug that brought him a gift
you know he reminded me of the time I
gave him a cookie and forgot to mention
that it was a THC you know you did yes I
did he put it in his freezer into the a
that like a day later and he started
getting all these little emotions of
love and it was just really interesting
to go down and get my hug and you know
he left a note for my nice doctor don't
bother him with needles he's not gonna
do it
trying to talk to him about a tetanus
shot before I'd love to get him on the
pot only get him to give blood in the
mornings he needs a window and then I
gave blood this afternoon no I did a
podcast at Mercy this my daughters in
studio today
she's got here phones on the podcast
were three about science yeah we do
whatever you say yeah we do one every
Tuesday it's called a science of mercy
and you know this morning while I was
taping her podcast I was actually
preparing to give blood and she stopped
her podcast to ask me daddy what are you
doing and I'm like I gotta go for a
physical I know I'm gonna have to give
them blood so I might as well practice
or do me practice I put my arm I believe
I'm getting raped I tried to think it
just getting raped somebody climbed on
top of me and raping me and I can't push
with my land because like your blood
that's exactly what I feel huh I have to
let myself feel Restless I won't give
the blood I have to put my arm out and
go take me I'm yours if not it's not
gonna work I'm just live an hour and
your brain and just you're going to be
when I'm gone but listen my fear of
needles grand rampant rampant for years
who really really need to know was no I
beat you I cuz you you go I mean I was a
guy that didn't refuse to go to a doctor
from the age of 19 didn't go to a
dentist for 15 years you know if anybody
said anything about a needle I just
instantly froze
I met Waxler it took me a little time I
started giving him one blood thinning a
year and I would faint then they figured
out they put me in a room with Windows
they put ice on my head and tip it over
and they said bring music bro I worked
myself up from going in there I would
have to bring a sandwich and a can of
soda what
all guys come on you know I'm scared of
all that stuff I was the biggest [ __ ] I
would go there with us with sandwich I
would take us can I cover call or me the
replies to sugar and let bring up like a
doughnut it's blood that was my that was
my that was my present and then I Drive
the Congo to Lulu's and that breakfast
after the sandwich on the doughnut oh
yeah you know me 400 pounds they do you
get there cuz the only one this is out
great okay
when you go give blood you can't eat
before you go your blood right are you
crazy
that killed I can't leave the house
laude I get dizzy when I'm driving I
would have to drive have my wife drive
me down a I'd be crying the whole way
you have no idea what I suffered those
first five years well I'll never forget
what the sleep apnea like I had to call
him and get his word and I had nothing
to do with it neither sleep apnea went
down there oh I did this stuff when I
was like someone I was like so ya know
that would you were six I was a grown
adult I was a thirty year old adult
clothes I was no needles well you figure
when I first went into waxed or Hanna's
where I had to be 30-something years old
my god first time I went on why I didn't
know I had waxer available to me I went
to the emergency room for my tooth cuz I
had that you know I used to take my
teeth down so I pulled on my Melissa but
one molar broke and it standing he and I
had an abscess and they would swell up
and I would push it and possibly come
out and if I was at the Comedy Store
around people I didn't like I would push
the back of my tooth and the pus would
shoot out and hit him on their neck oh
he Josh wolf and Joe Rogan knew and they
loved what I did to people please go get
that tooth fixed it's creeping me out I
got now I love it that my puss shooter
he's just shoot positive people with
this tooth it was like a little Fang I
finally Steve Simone's brother's a
dentist
yeah he took it out and put Freight
teeth they're so funny when to Steve's
mom's brothers do you suppose brother
my dog I going in with a phony insurance
claim we type up whatever allegedly
allegedly had a bunch of full of penis
then we trying to sell me on stuff and
he'd be in the back don't do it oh my
god Steve Sam oh brother was my dentist
for years know that down in Santa Monica
they had left me and I was pissed at
Steve for a year because he left me that
1500 left on my tooth plan on the
insurance I was gonna go down there but
when I went down he wasn't denim lost
the 1500 on my [ __ ] teeth I was
pissed at Steve like 6 months its feet
where's your [ __ ] brother because I'm
dying move back to Philadelphia nobody
told me what type but dentist is he
doesn't even send you a postcard
to let you know he's retirement I'm
surprised you didn't go to Philly and I
was furious at him I just recently
started talking to Steve about his
brother how the dentist is doing because
this tooth has worked it stayed there
Salam's got a lifetime guarantee so you
people don't care about a lifetime
guarantees as far as the anniversary was
concerned Monday I knew that it was our
anniversary
it was our ten-year anniversary and I
went on Facebook and my wife had posted
the picture and I started crying
not that I had forgotten it was our
anniversary I just started crying
because I accomplished something
like even today with dr. Waxler if you
know anything about me I was a type of
guy would quit a doctor you know I would
quit things like nothing I hung out with
dr. wack so for 21 years I haven't been
approached by a thousand doctors they
come over here come on Chicago dog every
time he goes to Chicago he brings back
meat and the buns and he freezes and he
says that he wakes up in the middle of
nights and nights and puts him cook
something nice he steams the bread he
would tell me how he'd steamed the bread
perfectly with a paper towel and stuff
he's just a great doctor
so I just wanted to thank him but what a
lot of people don't know is you know it
was a barbecue joint on 48th Street and
they died we went in and bought barbecue
beef I don't know anything about you
know brisket I didn't know anything
about ribs then enough I know about
Chinese ribs you know my mom always got
spareribs but I don't know what barbecue
really was I must have been five or six
and I was going every day whatever I
want to my godmothers house 148 this
barbecue choy was just a small little
place and their specialty is BBQ beef
sandwiches some two pieces of Wonder
Bread and it was just delicious laying
you know what an inch of meat between
and God knows what I was eating cat
fingernails wouldn't do you know it was
the 70s baby the best of what they got
you know but the guy was an
african-american guy and I took a like
him home in fact he used to let us help
him work you know which was nice he
would like I told you yesterday little
Street when you're in New York and you
see those things that go down underneath
the business he would let him catch you
know even let us carry stuff and trade
for them for food and stuff but he just
always say an expression and I never
know what he was saying it was called
till the wheels fall off like I'll be
here till the wheels fall off he'd go
out ha be hit the wheels fall off and
one day I what does that mean he's like
when the wheels fall off was then it
means you're him baby you know y'all in
y'all anything or did you see the way
you guys hang out together you guys are
gonna hang out into the wheels fall off
so it became like a state of mind to me
so the wheels fall off means that I got
you I got you bro you know I'm saying
like this is it we're friends for life
I got you Tony Puerto Ricans show up I
gotta fly them with your back to back
and you have to do the same for me don't
think that this is a one-way [ __ ]
street and sometimes it is and then you
stop you don't live in with those people
like that but it's really weird that
that's what since engraved inside our
wedding mats
- the wheels fall off so you know when
good
helped and whatever that you know to the
wheels fall off is something that we
live by it it's already Thanksgiving
guys listen it's already Thanksgiving
and something else is happening the year
is coming to an end it's officially over
you might hit the lottery mainly if all
the Angels align but besides that you
know you might pluck a job but right now
everything dies people after the at the
December 7th of 8th everybody's talking
about jingle bells and jingle balls and
Christmas is on where they going I'm
already thinking about 2012 I'm already
thinking of my goal what things I have
to perk up I really got to get this book
you know as much as I ran I gotta get
this book off the shelf if not it's it's
gonna be you know I have to do so many
things too lately and I talked about the
podcast about maybe taking music off so
we could put it on Spotify you know it's
November and I'm already looking at 2020
listen this year's over with whatever
happened happened where there is a good
year a bad year you lived through it you
made it you're here now you have to see
how we're gonna get better for 2020 you
know I'm gonna get better in 2020 and
leaves I'm gonna be a little bit better
than what he is now in 2020 my
daughter's gonna be a little bit better
than what she is and I'm counting on the
church family to all strive to be better
in 2020 and we'll Joe it's easy for you
to say no it's easy I don't want you to
go from hero to zero or zero in a hero I
just want you to take two baby steps
it's one foot at a time to get to your
goal whatever you'd call might beat you
want to be a DJ you want to be a fighter
you want to switch your career you know
we talk a lot about switching careers
here it's going for what you love and
going for what you love makes your life
a lot easier you know we all sixty
percent of people who have a job it's
very it's very seldom that people really
enjoy their job I don't even care what
I'm making a year I really enjoy what
the hell I'm doing them if I was doing
it if I was looking for real money I
would've just join Markel's if you're
looking for that type of money just go
to Mexico and bring back coke I don't
know what to tell you
real money what you're looking for is
just to be content be proud of what
you're doing you know Italian man for
years I lived in disgust of myself
frustration disgust wasn't talked maybe
which I had mercy that I started seeing
the light because now I had to act a
certain way you know and just chill I'll
be my wife for 20 years we celebrated a
10-year wedding anniversary Monday and I
gotta tell you something man I never
thought I couldn't come up with stuff
after I failed as a husband the first
time marriage was the last thing on my
mind and for me to be married for 10
years you know I'd like to tell you guys
I found the right woman that's excuse me
you all give us ha ha
we found the right woman no we decided
to fight for what we believe for the
first woman I was married for was a very
sweet girl but she went through four or
five six years the hell with me you know
and you know what when I was with and
even towards the end there was no future
this is how this is how much of a change
of men there was no future because I
wasn't content what I was doing forget
all that listen man I got into comedy
and it's till the wheels fall off that's
all I got to tell you guys Mercy Diaz
can I talk to you on do you want to sit
with us for five minutes
you don't want to say hello to the
people and tell them about yours
science with mercy okay she's good
ladies and gentlemen there you have it
there you have it she didn't want to
tell him but at least I brought it I
brought it to the office she wanted to
see what I did she does her own podcast
so I told her that this is what we need
to do and this is how we do it she's
been doing
she's have to podcast number eight
already there for her and she's only
taking the week of the 30th off like we
are tried to take her birthday week I've
asked her she's like I don't want to do
it the week before my that you do we do
it every week this is called consistency
there's no days off you want something
to happen you got to be consistent
that's been plain and simple you want
something to happen you got to be
consistent every day
look at this guy coming home boom he
wants a war he keeps sending out
missiles trumpets over that scratch
there's a wig
no we're at beefs we're friends get this
guy still shooting off fireworks and get
the fourth of July over there
King young moon you know whatever its
goddamn name I'm not good with politics
yeah yeah you know I'm not gonna that's
the imagine if you were president you're
tweeting out this w in tweet they living
vagin for Trump to be back oh please
forget about it I'm a savage I give it
to our there's but anyway if you travel
and be safe this weekend remember
Thanksgiving this is a Hallmark card
tomorrow Thanksgiving this tomorrow
please enjoy your families no I stop but
one thing
Thanksgiving is every day because when
you're pissin in the morning when you
wake up if you're not saying God thank
you for giving me another day later to
get a handle a little bit you're [ __ ]
missing the boat I give that I'm one of
those grateful people there is I'm
grateful for my shoelaces I'm grateful
for the weed I smoke I'm grateful for
everything because I knew it was a time
when I was homeless as how and I had
nothing or five years without a
residence Lee I wanted people something
I can do and then before that like I had
you know an 84 I was homeless and stuff
like that but that was cause of drugs
because I was a nuisance to society this
was hours of love with something and I
slung that I'm homeless
you know I'm saying life and I was 3/4
together I was doing on a couple of
criminal things but the homelessness was
due to me wanting to do comedy what it
meant to me and yeah there's highs and
lows and anything you do in this life
man but hey who gives a [ __ ]
it's Thanksgiving man enjoy your
family's real quick I'm in Miami this
weekend it sold out I don't know what to
tell you I can't help you out
I put the tickets up for sale a while
ago I'm sorry I will come back to Miami
in 2020 whatever we'll figure out a
bigger venue or whatever New York is
singular tickets left and they raised
all the prices on them so do not feel
bad I'm done you know they don't expect
me to pay over $30 so move on we got
21st Christmas
uncle Joey at the ice house and then we
got the 27th in Colusa casino and the
28th in San Francisco Palace of
Performing Arts and you got you got the
belly room - we got the belly room sold
out oh that's the workout for the
one-man show listen this podcast is
brought to you by manscape manscape over
the years I've had thousands sponsors I
really enjoy manscape I really enjoy
what manscape does
I like the bag I like all the everything
they got they used to have a manscape
lawn mower called up 1.0 and they
upgraded their trimmer with the
skin-safe technology for you mow mows in
the back that means it won't Nick or a
snag your nutsack plus it's perfect to
travel for I take it with me and it's
easy to charge you put it right against
the wall you could manscape wherever you
go
I'd do it one-handed while I'm on the
phone with Lee talking about life
manscape will have her landing on your
little Plymouth [ __ ] I mean Rock anyway
if this is the first time you've
considered manscaping they got the deal
for you I got the deal for you you ready
grab a pen it's called the perfect
package because it comes with a
lawnmower 2.0 and the safety razor plus
plus it comes with it comes with a thing
called the crop preserver especially
formulated deodorant so your balls don't
stink and trust me they smell worse than
the Mayflower and the Reviver
it's a spritz that tones and refreshes
your junk to keep it all if I show you
my balls right now they're right there
90 if I spray them with the spritz ten
minutes later it's like putting
eyeshadow on let's say he's I'm 22 it
tightens your stuff up and with your
perfect package your pouch will be
padded and your pole will be perfect
what are you waiting for
grab a pen go to manscape com pressing
code Church and if you order the perfect
package they're gonna throw on a free
travel bag for you that you're gonna
love they got a zipper in it you can put
reefer in there who's better than you is
I'm saying any of this local Joey its
crank call crank call anyway go to
manscape calm right now use promo code
church and get 20% off your first order
if you order the perfect package don't
throw in the free travel bag gratis just
your promo code Church that's manscape
also the
is brought to you by one of my personal
favorites we've been with them for years
you know some people say is there a
warranty on this product listen a bidet
a portable bidet that you can destroy
yourself in less than 10 seconds and
change your whole life
Joey how's it but they gonna change my
whole way you've ever Chinese girls
spitting you [ __ ] it's tremendous not
eliminate the Chinese girl feeling costs
too much money
just take it on upkeep just the cabbage
somebody just spit in the [ __ ] for an
hour like that that's what a bidet does
it's beautiful they start at $79 sprays
your ass with fresh water not toilet
water - she connects to the water supply
behind your toilet to spray a little
dirty parts clean with fresh water the
same water you brought your tweet your
teeth with wet wipes are worse than
toilet paper that terrible free
environment they cause anal fissures and
you don't want no anal fissures listen
to she started $79 I got different
colors different styles tushies latest
product the cushy Adelman helps you get
everything out now you're saying to me
Joey what do I want to use tissue you
know why because it sprays directly nice
clean water in TS and removes the poop
completely so you are a sitting on
bacteria that leads to hemorrhoids yeast
infection UTI and the worst thing ever
itchy ass so you ever have an itchy ass
on the middle of the day you gotta
figure out how to scratch [ __ ] and
then you're scared that if you scratch
it smells too bad and you're left over
like you haven't let the key lasting you
sitting there yeah asses on fire for no
reason this because you got a little
have to growth like you left a little
bit of bow around the rim my ass is on
fire usually that's not gonna happen
with tushy because it gets deep in there
and you won't have that you're a hassle
feel refreshed
it's like putting mister in your mouth
in the morning you kill all the germs of
maluca germs do me a favor go to hell
Toshi calm right now take a look at the
best portable bidet in the business
pick one I'm gonna give you a 10% off
your order when you press in church on
the way out all right I love douchey
I've been using it for three is they
have a 60-day guarantee but Lee's got
one and I got one and in fact our fat
asses haven't broken it your little
skinny bony ass won't do no damage to it
either that's it and that's that
listen I want to thank Telo tushy I want
to thank manscape but most importantly I
want to wish you and all your families a
happy Thanksgiving you guys are great
thank you for the support the love and
we'll be back Tuesday tip top Magoo the
second of December ready to rock crack
that [ __ ] melee